what is a woman but the Brits aren't
afraid to answer it Britain's prime
minister Rishi sonak standing up to the
radical left's gender insanity and
making our American leaders look like
wimps and it also shouldn't be
controversial for parents to know what
their children are being taught in
school about relationships patients
should know when hospitals are talking
about men or women and we shouldn't get
bullied into believing that people can
be any sex they want to be they can't
man is a man and a woman is a woman
that's just common sense I love this do
you hear all the Applause Greg over
there imagine if Biden said that uh he
couldn't do that couldn't no no no but
then you know this issue a lot of people
say it's not a big deal it actually is a
big deal here uh because it's about
seizing control over the kids from their
parents under this phony ruse of privacy
right this is just between me and the
activist so it's Shifting the parental
bond to sick activists who have scared
the Cowardly School administrators and
liberal politicians to playing along but
even more than that and this is why it's
even more disgraceful in the United
States it's about speech this is the
first time at least that I've seen in
our history that it's okay for others to
compel you to use words it's not about
silencing your speech it's compelling
you to use certain words but freedom of
speech is allow also involves the
rejection of people forcing you to say
things that's where we are right now
it's worse here because everything is
worse here right now we're elevating and
supporting the very things that
ultimately destroy this country whether
it's border crime speech Science
Education sorry I'm a downer today no
it's an interesting point that you
you're made to say something if someone
is a doctor you don't have to call him
doctor yeah but if you if someone says
I'm transgender you have to call him
they or him or whatever not binary right
or you're in trouble You' be accused of
misgendering right and they didn't go to
four years of medical school right I I
think reishi reishi sunak is um you know
you heard the Applause in the room he
he's understanding that people will be
receptive to this message in the United
Kingdom he he's he's leading in an
interesting way right now he's also
Banning cell phones and all the
classrooms in the UK which is a
brilliant move which we should do
tomorrow because kids can't learn
because they're constantly distracted
and teachers don't have the leadership
in many cases to tell them that they
have to get off their phone leadership
is sorely lacking the ability to stand
up and have a spine and say this is
right and that is wrong and people can
disagree with you they can they can tell
you that they think you're full of it
they cannot elect you at the next
election but we can't we must have the
ability to be leaders it goes to the
school University presidents as well
they need to be able to step up and be a
leader everyone is afraid to lead these
days and this is an enormous problem so
we all turn into these mush balls you
know just repeating things that we're
supposed to say to certain people you
you should not not be out you should not
be in fear for your future by standing
it all started with cancel culture
really and it just permeated society and
you know you get like lifted eyebrows
and everything else if you if you say
what you think and feel he said we we
have we were favoring values over virtue
signaling that's what he wants you're a
recovering politician you know as a
politician that voters may not agree
with you but if they know where you
stand clearly on an issue they respect
that I agree with you look I agree with
the ukuk Prime Minister um we are all
born with a defined gender uh it's on
our birth certificate um but we are all
allowed uh and all are permitted to
pursue our our own happiness protected
by uh the freedoms that we enjoy in this
great country with the people we love
and for that matter how we want to lead
Our Lives as long as we stay within the
Realms of the law um but this point is
one that needs to be made over and over
again we we're all born with a defined
gender period and we should we should
accept that does it kind of bother you
deep down that the British kind of can
say what they feel and the Americans are
afraid after destroying them in the
Revolutionary War yeah well the
interesting thing is it's really the
ones on the left that are the the wusses
but I mean what it comes down to is
we're being bullied into believing that
people can be any sex they want to be
and that's just absurd I mean if your if
your genitals don't determine your
gender how does remove moving those
genitals affirm your gender I mean none
of this makes sense to me and I think
that parents need to know that 10
million children in this country are in
schools where the guidance is that uh
the parents are being blocked from
knowing whether or not their child
identifies as a different sex from their
birth sex so this is a real problem and
parents have to go out there and find
out what the schools are doing and what
they're preventing you from knowing
something about the way you say
judge don't even go there just rolls
right off your I enjoyed mush balls mush
balls hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else